He gave me the ingredients of the betyba, ingredients organic refined,
expelled, compressed, coconut oil, organic natural flavors, organic,
anato extract for color.
Yeah, I mean, we just don't know what's in the organic natural flavors.
Could be organic, not as only glutamate, but that's the sad thing about life.
What are you going to do? So you have to pick your mammals.
So, yeah, if you like that, I would eat it.
I'll have to look that up and see what that looks good.
Yeah, I don't think that's an issue.
It doesn't have any GMO fermented plants, no sunflower.
So yeah, I would, if you like that, that's fine.
And follow up in the previous question,
if you've any cashews often, if you've any cashews often,
and it wasn't the equivocal range, you probably just lay off for a while.
If you don't want to go to the expensive of doing another Cyrex 10,
then just stop eating and they were, you missed that one or something,
or you were only staying off the red ones in the out of range things.
That's fine. I would just, if they were the equivocal in the past,
you don't want to do another Cyrex 10,
then make sense to just, well, I'm just not going to eat them.
Now, maybe I should just stay off the red ones, switch to something else.
It's always good, you know, we tend to, as humans,
get into a rut with our diets, that we eat the same thing all the time.
And I just don't think I'd preach this over and over again.
I just don't think that we were created to eat,
to be able to eat apples year-round.
I'm using apples as an example.
We were supposed to eat things in season.
We were supposed to have a seasonal diet.
We're supposed to have a rotational diet.
You know, I think there's benefit to that.
And most people that are listening to me right now,
could remember the day when you went to the grocery store,
and it was one fourth, one tenth the size of the grocery store
is today.
And, you know, in January, there were no strawberries for sale.
No, there were no blueberries for sale.
You couldn't get a watermelon.
These days, they're shipping from all over.
They're grown in greenhouses.
They're, you know, we get in from Peru.
And, you know, we have things completely out of season to us.
And even not.
So, okay, well, that's store, well, well, again,
you didn't necessarily have the ability to eat cashews on a, you know, daily basis all year-round.
We just didn't have the ability to have so much food in front of us all the time.
So, I think there's a huge benefit for our gut,
in our microbiome to have a very rotational diet.
There's many studies out there now that the greater diversity of food that we consume,
it changes our microbiome.
When our microbiome, the flora that's in our gut can change very quickly with food diversity.
If we just changed our diet where we're eating a lot of different foods and a lot of rotational foods
are weak in a, in one weaker microbiome could be completely changed.
And that could bring a lot of health and, and decrease a lot of comorbidity.
So, think about that as well.